70% of the audience stood up you got
your perspective
[Music]
your dad did your dad ever do it you do
where you take office
so that was
you know I mean honestly I don't judge
my death I don't think I'm over
compensating for the I mean the fact of
the matter is and this is just so insane
literally yesterday yesterday spending
the day with my family and kids on a
weekday was more weekday spent with my
kids then my dad spent with us until I
was 16 years old like
so now at the same token my dad you know
somewhere around seventh or eighth grade
my dad started coming home at seven
instead of like ten that I don't do that
Monday through Friday so you know I mean
I think ultimately work-life balance and
with family businesses as we start you
know spend a lot of time on parenting as
we start thinking about as I'm crying
you know I think a lot of times people
like Gary tell me things that don't come
natural I'm like sure things don't come
natural to me either
I don't naturally you know all the time
think of family business stuff from my
content standpoint which is what I'm
trying to do for a living but it's
popped up once in a while the same way
that once in a blue moon in January you
go out to the gym some days you decide
to be positive instead of negative once
in a while you work 12 hours a day so
once in a while I think of something
about family businesses and I talk about
it but right now what we're doing and
this is very meta of a video is I'm
trying to be thoughtful of like hey this
is a subject matter that really matters
there are tens of millions of people in
family businesses hundreds of millions
hundreds of millions across the world
that are going to be able to
you know that I'm gonna be able to add
my two cents whether they're you know I
think they'll be good but they're just
my two cents but taking it out of the
meta conversation of what we're doing
here which i think is important for me
too I think there's a way for me to be
more thoughtful action than do it right
now another thing that's good about
vacations is there's this whole notion
of like breaking the fourth wall Google
and if you don't understand it so many
of you ask me so many questions the
answers always googling anyway you know
what does he mean by that
you know what are the Joneses Google
that [ __ ] baby
if you can't Google stuff you're not
gonna be able to do anything that I'm
telling you to do you know I think I can
do a better job of like breaking my own
fourth wall and explaining what I'm
doing in real time within it what I'm
doing right now is trying to forcefully
consciously recognize that one of the
great pillars that I could be speaking
to is family business dynamics you know
me and my dad and then me and my brother
have architected two very successful
family businesses I had a lot of tough
days growing up with my dad I some not
very infrequent with my brother I'm sure
they have something to say about it
but most of all like anything else I
have no interest in being a focus group
of one my experiences aren't your
experiences I think what I've had the
luxury of is I've been out and about for
the last decade and especially last
three or four years especially last two
years have consumed just an enormous
amount of conversations with people from
all angles dad son is lazy mom daughters
lazy daughter mom will let her do
anything daughter dad won't let her do
anything son mom won't let him do
anything son dad won't let them do
anything lazy entitled ownership you
know it's a lot their parents want kids
to do certain things but don't recognize
they have options and if they don't give
them freedom to do [ __ ] well then that's
not going to be exciting it's gonna be
worse than doing something else kids
come in at 22 I think that they got good
grades in school and that means
something after their parents have been
bleeding from their face 15 hours a day
you know for 23 years and they walk in
like they own the own the business and
that's laughable parents want to
navigate and respect employees that have
been there for 7 9 13 22 years and not
let little Sally come in and just be the
CEO from day one they have to balance
that sally has to have empathy that
employees have been there for 22 years
and have helped how do you think you
went on that spring break Sally not only
on the back of your parents but on the
back of Carl who's been the manager for
16 years so when you walk in day one
don't be a dick because that's how you
got to like funnel beer in Daytona you
know instead of working so there's a lot
of dynamics I've got a lot of thoughts
and yeah I'm excited about talking about
family business nonetheless back to the
regularly scheduled programs
I don't I don't know maybe
subconsciously it's an overcorrection
but like I don't you know I just want to
spend time with them meaning like yeah
the way that like net volume of time
quality like you know you have been off
last few weeks yes yes but I've also
been very on to like all of a sudden
miraculously deciding I need to be in
the baseball card business like so you
know I let one thing I never want to do
is [ __ ] the audience like yes I'm
spending time with the family which is
amazing
but but my mind is wired a certain way
and just like when the kids are eating
or or like playing with each other and
don't want us you know they're getting
like like it's not in my DNA to just lay
there and listen to Elton John or skip
of the Flippa like it's in my DNA to do
something business see that doesn't have
the pressures of the business that I'm
running so the thought process of like
really upping my game in my flipping
content I mean I really had a
breakthrough in the deep you know 20 I'm
here in Orlando and in DC which I spoke
last week
I really had a breakthrough asked the
audience there's a lot of people there
how many people want to make a hundred
thousand a year and I really got them to
that honest place where people weren't
trying to showboat seventy percent of
the audience stood up seventy so I was
like okay cool now we're in an authentic
conversation enough with this like
million dollar or bust you know so it's
like okay and I was like [ __ ] man the
flip game is real I can get you to 100 I
can get you know hundred with Craigslist
and let go and Etsy and eBay and you
know and though so many people want me
to make the content that helps I'm
looking at Lexus right now and Nike and
DKNY and coach and New Balance and Steve
Madden was perfect all these brands and
about social media and marketing and
making that nature I'd be lying if I
didn't say that I was so drawn to you
know I'm very into my roots I'm very
into it I just also know I can do it I
know I know it's not glamorous doesn't
seem like this remarkable you know not a
genius not a maven but I know that I
could walk into that Tommy Hilfiger
right there and zoom at the rock don't
be a dick there you go
I know I could walk into that Tommy
Hilfiger outlet store right I know that
I could search things uncompleted
auction completed auctions not listing
price a lot of people look at what it's
listed for it doesn't mean it's sold it
for a completed auction price
make money with one of them
20:17 flip challenge help people I
didn't do a 20-18 one uh but I think
2019 will be the year of the flip I I
literally think I'm very passionate
about it and we're definitely filming
this garage sale the first Saturday and
it's gonna be you're gonna kill it and
then the sports card unpacking thing
like of course brother who do you think
I am I'm gonna buy the New York Jets for
billions of dollars on the back of like
flipping sports cards you have to learn
this is a step by step game everybody
tries to get if I said to somebody
you're gonna win Wimbledon and they have
never played tennis they think that's
ludicrous
somehow though people think from zero
never having a business in their life
have always been a student or an
employee that on the motivation of one
of my [ __ ] videos that they're gonna
build a million dollar business the next
day a million dollar but making a
million dollars forget about even
revenue making a million dollars it's
like winning [ __ ] a tennis tour like
getting to the quarterfinals of
Wimbledon cold are you gonna really do
that Carl in Jacksonville Carl you're
gonna really just pick up a racquet and
win [ __ ] Wimbledon it's the same thing
of like okay now I'm motivated now I'm
gonna do a business yes you should but
why don't we take one step at a time and
if you're and the reason people don't is
cuz there's 39 and they think it's over
and I'm like being happy at 52 is really
interesting for 36 years
I just don't the utter lack of
practicality
is remarkable the the inability to
contextualize time is the great
vulnerability of so many you know I've
never been more passionate that kids
need to go high-risk high-reward 20 to
30 I've never been more passionate that
a 47 year old single parent with a job
and debt and child support and all this
stuff can do so much from 7:00 p.m. to
2:00 we are not taking advantage of the
long tail of the internet because of
lack of education of what the
opportunity actually is and the lack of
patience and it's just raw matically
easier to dwell and complain in it and
point fingers than it is to eat the [ __ ]
to do it it's absolutely like exercise
it's a hell of a lot easier to buy
miracle pills than to eat right for a
year and do the right exercise
it's not super complicated you know it's
um it's outrageously obvious
are we sitting in unusual traffic are we
gonna be okay
car fire up here I think and still make
our time yeah okay good
[Music]
you know like I feel like people might
think you're in heaven like I and I love
that I don't value my time more than
somebody else's and even work more than
that I I would hate for somebody to
think that you know they're like the two
most evil things for me you know what I
really dislike something I really got to
do a better job with is when I have to
cancel on somebody two or three or four
times just the sheer nature of my life
right now we need a better system you
know
[Music]